le tee shirt que je porte ce soir n'est
pas très adaptée à l'événement
j'en ai bien conscience mais il était
important pour moi que je le porte ce
soir parce que c'est le début de
l'histoire que je voudrais vous raconter
ça se passe un vendredi soir
je suis avec mon fils et on va voir un
concert nous on habite à lyon mais pour
voir ce groupe il ne passe qu'à paris
donc on a décidé d'aller à paris et puis
c'est l'occasion également de passer un
petit week end à paris avec mon fils
tous les deux ça sera la première fois
que lui va voir paris et puis ça
coïncide aussi même avec son
anniversaire et doit avoir cette en
trois jours après donc on arrive à ce
concert et on achète ce tee shirt tout
de suite en arrivant et on va en acheter
un homme qui va mourir
deux heures plus tard dans le chaos le
plus total
c'était le 13 novembre 2015 et c'était
au bataclan
bon alors vous le voyez je vais bien on
va bien mon fils va bien également il
est là avec nous ce soir je vais pas
vous raconter en détail tout ce qui
s'est passé ce soir là parce que vous
avez déjà eu tous les détails je pense
dans les médias que ce n'est pas le
propos de ce soir mais je vais vous
donner quelques éléments pour que vous
compreniez un petit peu ce qu'on a vécu
quand on va voir un concert avec un
enfant de 7 ans on se met pas dans la
fosse forcément puisque toutes les
personnes qui se mettent devant lui sont
plus grandes que lui donc il ne voit
rien donc on était au balcon c'est ce
qui nous a permis finalement d'avoir un
petit peu de temps pour une tenter de
nous mettre à l'abri et donc on a fini
dans le grenier
après quelques péripéties et on est
restées là jusqu'à la fin et c'est les
policiers de la bmi qui sont venus nous
chercher
après avoir donné l'assaut après là
encore fallu retraverser toute la salle
je vous passe les détails
et puis ça s'est terminé sur le trottoir
devant le bataclan tous les deux avec
mon fils il était à peu près 1h30 du
matin
et puis après ça bah qu'est ce qui se
passe comment on fait - naïvement je
pensais qu'après deux ou trois jours de
flottement tout allait rentrer dans
l'ordre
ça s'est pas du tout passé comme ça au
lieu de ça j'ai découvert les joies du
stress post traumatique et des choses
comme l'hyper vigilance alors
hypervigilance dit comme ça ça a l'air
super on dirait un petit peu à un nom de
super pouvoirs mais pas du tout c'est
juste la capacité
faire un bond de 3 mètres une crise
cardiaque à chaque fois qu'un stylo qui
tombe par terre c'est pas terrible mais
heureusement ça dure pas ça dure pas
mais il faut quand même tout réapprendre
derrière moi j'ai décidé de ne pas
prendre de médicaments parce que j'ai
deux enfants à m'occuper que je voulais
être capable de m'en occuper
et puis j'ai choisi aussi de ne pas en
parler autour de moi à part un cercle
très très proches
déjà parce que je n'ai pas envie de
devoir la pitié dans les yeux des gens
et puis aussi parce que quelque part ça
m'arrangeait finalement j'avais pas
envie que quand on aille au café ce soit
les autres qui me disent ah bah tiens
takata soir là tu seras à côté de la
sortie de secours tu seras bien non je
serai bien partout j'ai pas besoin de
m'asseoir à côté de la sortie de secours
je vais pas passer ma vie à côté des
sorties de secours
ça sert à rien moi ce que je veux c'est
juste vivre normalement ne pas y penser
et pour ça il faut faire les choses par
étapes moi j'y suis allé doucement en
m'écoutant mais quand même en mettant un
bon coup de pied au cul parce que
j'avais envie d'avancer
la première chose que je voulais faire
c'était retourner voir un concert est le
premier concert qui s'est présenté
c'était le même groupe qui est remonté
sur scène quatre mois plus tard à
l'olympia ça n'a pas été facile il a
fallu retourner à paris il a fallu
retourner dans une salle de concert
fermé il a fallu retourner voir le même
groupe entendre les mêmes chansons ça
faisait beaucoup de choses à la fois
mais en même temps j'avais très envie de
revoir tous les gens avec qui j'avais
vécu ça et de vivre cette nouvelle
expérience avec eux à nouveau alors ça a
été difficile mais nécessaire
on va y retourner là bas avec mon fils
et avec mon mari et c'était un très beau
concert
et puis après il ya eu plein d'autres
concerts ce que j'avais l'habitude de
faire même un petit peu plus que ce que
j'avais l'habitude de faire et puis à un
moment j'ai eu besoin de retourner au
bataclan
la première fois que j'ai su retourner
c'était dans le cadre de visites vont
nous a ouvert le baquet du bataclan
spécialement pour nous c'était pour
pouvoir revoir un petit peu les lieux et
se réapproprier peut-être certaines
choses qui pouvaient nous nous manquer
mais ce que je voulais surtout
c'était retourner faire un concert au
bataclan parce que ça reste une salle de
spectacle et c'est un endroit où il faut
qu'on s'amuse et j'ai trouvé une artiste
qui respire la joie de vivre qui est
vraiment très drôle très chaleureuse et
j'étais sûr qu'elle ait pas faire dans
le pathos et j'avais vraiment besoin de
ça et donc on est retourné voir cet
artiste au bataclan avec mon fils et mon
mari à nouveau on s'est vraiment bien
amusé
et puis après il a fallu que je retourne
faire un week end juste tous les deux
avec mon fils pour aller voir un concert
voilà j'avoue j'ai un peu triché j'ai
contourné le problème on n'est pas allé
voir un concert on est allé voir un
spectacle musical
la nuance est mince mais j'en avais
vraiment besoin
et puis le spectacle ils ont joué un
vendredi et un samedi et je me suis
trouvé toutes les excuses possibles pour
ne pas y aller le vendredi
la vérité c'est que j'aurais pas pu y
aller un vendredi
quand je suis tout seul j'ai aucun
problème avec les jours de la semaine
j'ai pas d'angoissé particulière à ce
niveau là mais quand je suis avec mon
fils il ya le poids de la responsabilité
puis sûrement encore pas mal de
culpabilité donc du coup on est allé
voir ce spectacle le samedi et on a fait
ce petit week-end tous les deux et
maintenant la prochaine étape ce sera la
prochaine fois qu'on ira se faire un
petit week-end tous les deux on ira voir
un concert pour de vrai et on ira le
voir au bataclan
mais ça ce sera un petit peu plus tard
bientôt
et toutes ces petites étapes elles m'ont
vraiment fait du bien parce que j'y suis
allé progressivement et à chaque fois
c'était comme une petite victoire pour
moi et je me suis rendu compte d'une
chose c'est que mon temps est précieux
je le passé avec les gens qui comptent
pour moi à faire des choses qui sont
importantes
je veux pas le perdre à penser aux gens
qui nous ont fait ça ils en valent pas
la peine ils ont trois heures de ma vie
ils n'auront pas une minute de plus
c'est moi qui décide du temps et de
l'importance que je vais accorder aux
gens aux choses aux événements j'ai
cette capacité là on l'a tous et j'ai
une anecdote à ce propos qui illustrent
bien ce que je pense c'est une amie à
moi qui un matin récupère sa voiture
avec un rétro en moins visiblement
quelqu'un s'était servi pendant la nuit
et elle va raconter ça le lendemain
sur facebook avec beaucoup d'humour et
de détachement et elle ajoute qu'elle a
dit à sa fille on nous a volé notre
rétro mais on ne volera pas notre
sourire et cette phrase si simple parce
qu'elle s'adresse à une enfant de très
jeune âge je les trouvais vraiment très
intéressante et très pertinente
en effet personne ne vous oblige à faire
la tête à vous laisser abattre par le
moindre chose qui vous arrive
on peut choisir de d'être heureux malgré
tout suffit de ne pas accorder
d'importance à ce qui se passe et si
vous êtes capable d'appliquer sa à
toutes les petites et les grosse
contrariété de la vie alors vous serez
toujours gagnant vous avez le pouvoir de
choisir de l'importance que vous
accordez aux choses c'est vous qui
décidez c'est vous qui choisissez
moi j'ai choisi je ne suis pas une
victime
je suis une survivante merci
[Applaudissements]